[Applause]
[Music]
give me one minute and I'll show you how
cloud run can help you create apps
quickly cloud run is a fully managed
compute environment that lets you easily
deploy stateless containers and
abstracts away infrastructure management
and scales up and down with your apps
traffic and you only pay when your code
is running cloud run is easy to use just
write your app using your favorite
language framework and or binary
libraries package the app is a container
and deploy it using G cloud run deploy
and just like that your app is live by
default your service gets an HTTP
endpoint with TLS termination on your
custom domain and some flower run is
built on the native open standard you
can easily move your applications to any
kubernetes clusters on GCP on Prem or in
another cloud using cloud run you can
build client urban web services such as
dynamic websites mobile app backends or
back-office administration you can also
use cloud run for creating automated
asynchronous micro services such as
lightweight data transformation
scheduled document generation or
business workflow automation next time
you're thinking about building an app
take a minute to look at cloud run to
learn more check out clouds a Broadcom
slash run